vous êtes connu où tous les deux à vos
confiant il ya enfin lui il était enfant
moi j'étais déjà adulte très âgées
personnes les femmes s'attendent
toujours pour moi oui petit de son livre
ouais enfin le kit andré bannon sert le
petit way un moment où tu aurais pas
facilement plus est acteur ou et huawei
acteurs vous voyez où nous voyons
wima facto city libraires en plus à
l'époque libraire bien apparu déjà donc
dans le commerce
alors c'était le café de la gare c'est
ça ouais avec robin et goisot mise en
scène romain bouteille c'est ça oui oui
et c'est là où tu as connu toute la
troupe avec nous avec des airs de
paradis
comment il était à ce moment là renault
découle responsable parlera du
restaurant du coeur à laquelle soir la
cotation
on va donner l'adresse et où toute heure
1 comment il était à ses débuts au camp
même d'en bas des quads timide depuis
parlait pas dans la rue par les parents
les coulisses il parlait pas et sur
scène ils eurent laissé c'est une nature
comme ça je crois en annonçant devrait
pas y avait un artiste je peux le citc
moustaki il m'avait dit si en tout cas
un jour je suis célèbre je viendrai pas
prétentieux que de ça j étais avant et
c'est sympa de lire son portrait vrai
dans son club enfin ça c'est bon alors
on se refait pas eu comme ça hein
ouais tu utilises resté combien de gens
j'ai fait de lier manque franchement
j'étais le corsage été aussi lorsqu'il
je suis resté je fait un passage éclair
quelques quelques semaines ah ouais pas
plus de trois mois à remplacer j'ai
remplacé gégé qui était par axione aux
états unis puis après il est revenu je
suis parti et c'est tata en vidant
remonter sur les planches maintenant
tous vous faire un peu de cinéma ou des
choses comme ça pas franchement non je
ne te demande à huy franck nivard de te
demander
oui alors et on ne propose pas des
choses bien suit pas toujours
oui c'est bien ce qui fait surtout c'est
ça ouais c'était fait des chansons il a
du succès il fait ce qu'il veut il se
fait ce qu'il aime c'est là il fait un
truc bien pourquoi tu veux en faire deux
c'est ça aussi toi dans notre métier on
est toujours me dit don alors puisque
vous avez du succès là dans la chanson
google fait pas au cinéma mais tu dis
pas un mec et qui a réussi dans dix à
mort pour que vous faites pas à
descendre
[Musique]